this video is sponsored by ag1 the
Buddha castle Exquisite architecture
incredible Panorama billions of
embezzled EU funds Hungarian Vladimir
Putin annual neonata Gatherings but this
epicenter of Hungarian culture boasts
something else not often talked about
public transportation what kind of
public transportation midi buses from
the mid-1990s The Budapest Transit
company launched the so-called Castle
bus service with the aforementioned
midibuses which are a third shorter than
normal solo buses for better
maneuverability inside the castle area
and its tight curves they were the
Icarus model 405 brand new domestically
made contemporary and massive pieces of
[__] the buses had more issues than a
Bethesda game on release day they had
problems with the engines the axles the
frame nearly every major component had
some fatal issue waiting to come out
they would constantly break down
sometimes Catch Fire and make passengers
nauseous due to their Drive
characteristics after years of constant
factory recalls and futile attempts to
fix them the Transit company finally
announced a tender for new midibuses
which failed so the 405 series remained
after years of desperate servicing and
even more desperate overhaul attempts
which for a lot of money made there was
a slightly less [__] The Budapest
Transportation Company finally received
brand new minibuses Turkish Carson
attack Diesel and Hungarian modulo Medio
electric buses however there is a
problem many problems in fact the
Turkish midi buses have a habit of
smoking I mean really smoking or just
spontaneously combusting while idle
that's because going up on steep
gradients all day is not something their
diesel engine can reliably do okay so
how about those battery buses the future
of Green Transportation ready to solve
the castle bus issue once and for all
well there are such [__] that as of this
year six out of the original 20 are
already scrapped seven years after
entering operation otherwise the
remaining 14 are set to produce 5 to 6
breakdowns per day their design is
terrible their frames are cracking they
don't tolerate Unity or cold weather and
they smoke during winter turns out the
heating on these electric buses is
operated by a gasoline-fired fern is in
the back oh and one of them also caught
fire about charging the castle bus has
been announced up two decade disaster
show for Budapest why can't they run
normal actually working Rolling Stock up
the damn hill well they wanted to
decades ago there were plans to lead
wires up the hill and run trolley buses
up and down the castle the electric
traction motor is much more reliable and
can handle steep gradients far better
than a combustion engine however thanks
to the influential bus Lobby the lines
were never put up and Budapest got stuck
with its current midi buses without such
a meaningful change the castle bus is
and will remain [__] not even shiny new
battery buses could solve the problem
because aside from all the construction
issues turns out slapping a big-ass
battery on a bus that has to go up and
down the hill constantly isn't the
smartest thing to do also they were
horribly expensive about twice the cost
of a regular large solo bus why have I
told you all this I wish I knew just
kidding I told you all this to
illustrate how fundamentally broken
systems cannot be fixed either by making
its parts slightly better or by slapping
batteries into it and calling it a day
and the situation is the same with
electric records only with them things
are much worse how is that possible let
me explain now electric cars are green
or so they say and so did you know
what's also agree okay so today's video
is sponsored by ag1 and it's green and
this was my attempt at a seamless
transition our returning sponsor ag1 is
a whole food dietary supplement for
everyday use containing 75 vitamins
minerals and Whole Food sourced
ingredients ag1 is gluten and dairy free
low calorie vegan and it's one of the
most comprehensive supplements on the
market made with the highest quality
ingredients preparing it takes just a
few seconds put a spoonful into a glass
of water and mix done ag1 tastes a bit
different to everyone but nonetheless
good The Taste is mild and the texture
is Pleasant it supports your immune
system maintains your energy level and
boosts your body's natural recovery
process it's especially useful for those
doing heavy physical work or training I
also drink ag1 every morning and I fear
better and more energetic since then go
to athleticgreens.com item something to
get started on your order ag1 is going
to give my community a free one-year
supply of immune super putting vitamin
D3 plus K2 and 5 travel packs for free
with your first purchase thanks to ag1
for sponsoring today's video so electric
cars and why they are a terrible
solution to our traffic and pollution
problems I should make it clear though
that electric cords are still slightly
better than gasoline cars slightly so
why won't electric cars or anything and
how could they make things actually
worse
electric cores are powered by gigantic
batteries and they're all fun and games
until it gets cold then many owners find
that their range can have even an E4
charge similarly when the weather gets
too hot electric car batteries are at
their Peak Performance at 21 degrees
Celsius anything above or below that
will result in performance loss but a
far bigger problem is battery
degradation for example the Tesla Model
S has an annual degradation rate of 2.3
percent according to this geotab article
So at around year 4 of ownership you are
already down to 90 percent and this is a
big issue in terms of the car's
reusability and the second hand Market
if you buy a 10 year old used electric
car now you have to pay for both the car
and the new battery which costs
thousands potentially tens of thousands
of dollars extra not to mention who will
process the millions of discorded
batteries each year should EVS get
popular enough but an even bigger
problem is 5
[Music]
core batteries are technically safe
unless you keep them in sub-optimal
conditions meaning when you use them in
areas where the temperature isn't 21
degrees Celsius and the roads aren't
perfectly smooth which tends to happen
around the globe if you run an EV in say
hot climate on bumpy roads that shake
the battery around for years there is a
higher chance it will spontaneously
combust this can already be observed
with electric buses there have been
numerous large fires around the world
where bus batteries just randomly caught
fire that's because buses are
intensively used often on imperfect Road
surfaces but some cars are also very
intensively used also on imperfect Road
surfaces so once EVS get widespread
enough and get enough years of operation
in many EVS will just become ticking
time bombs and Lord help you if one of
them goes off in a tunnel during a
traffic jam or something extinguishing
EVS is borderline impossible a
combustion car fire on average takes
1100 liters to put out in contrast a
Tesla takes between 11 and 30 000 liters
10 to 26 times more our fire departments
do not have the capacity to put out such
fires imagine if there is a 20 car
pileup on the highway and advs Catch
Fire aside from the fact that everyone
unable to get out will be vaporized
within minutes in the best case scenario
you would need something like 88 000
liters of water meaning each burning
electric car would need one full water
tender to put out at minimum so the more
likely scenario is that firefighters
will just let the cars burn out which
means the road surface below them will
be completely destroyed and will need
closures and repaving after each fire
speaking of Roads
we've all seen this Boomer meme about
Roman roads vs today's roads Roman roads
have stayed perfectly intact for
Millennia yet our new asphalt throws are
full of potholes after a year thanks
Engineers is the Roman roads famous for
having withstood the intense Roman truck
traffic the reason why our roads fall
apart quickly isn't Engineers it's
vehicle traffic increasing the weight of
a vehicle leads to exponential roadwear
so to cause as much road damage as one
Toyota Prius you would need
5633 fat men on freakishly heavy
bicycles to bike through a road section
and you would need
35612 to cause the same damage as a
Hummer does and thus the equivalent of
63 Priuses and to get the road damage
caused by a 9-ton big rig you would need
6.8 million Fatman or freaky Levy
bicycles biking through a given Road
section now a Tesla Model S's weight is
actually comparable to the Chevy Tahoe
causing Road wear equivalent to 59 575
fat men on freakishly heavy bicycles all
this is to say get ready for a tax
increase once EVS got popular enough
road damage caused by cars will at least
double and you'll be paying for the
repairs more road damage will of course
lead to bumpier roads which will give a
good shake to all those batteries so we
might even see more fires because of
that but the biggest most fundamental
unchangeable problem with electric cars
the reason why they won't solve our
problems is
when it comes to space use cars are
inherently inefficient and unsustainable
especially if used by everyone at mass
for example a six-lane highway might let
through around 112 000 vehicles per day
invested daily output of the Golden Gate
Bridge 112 000 vehicles with an average
U.S occupancy of 1.5 passengers is 168
000 people a six-lane highway for 168
000 people with the oldest Associated
infrastructure asphalt concrete surface
traffic barriers lighting ramps noise
barriers overpasses underpasses Wildlife
Bridges signage policing accident
Response Road Works quality checks
Landscaping cleaning all these expenses
to carry a third of the people in a day
that the boot attached M3 metro line
carries
or as a more American example the 26
Lane Katy Freeway carries 300 000 people
every day while the Bay Area Rapid
Transit carries 400 000. so this
two-track Urban rail actually beats this
monstrosity in terms of capacity not to
mention the costs which if you're an
American taxpayer you footed the bill
for this highway large-scale core
infrastructure is a fundamentally broken
system which we're now trying to fix by
slapping batteries into cars and calling
it a day but electric cars will not
solve this issue they will not solve the
inherent inefficiency and horrible
economy of cars and Roads if anything
they will actually make it worse by
causing way more road damage and making
excellent response an absolute nightmare
with all the associated additional costs
so what's the solution a public transit
that provides a practical convenient
alternative to driving and in cities
actually useful safe bike infrastructure
to give people the freedom to not have
to own a car to get around of course
this solution mostly applies to urban
areas in the countryside cars will
always be necessary but the vast
majority of people do not live in the
countryside anyway so it's fine this
infatuation with battery electric
vehicles will not solve anything it's
just a way to greenwash our problems and
for our politicians to pretend they're
doing something for the environment when
in fact they aren't so that's the reason
why as soon as battery cars battery
buses and Battery trains became a thing
those politicians who didn't give a
single [__] about public transit before
suddenly started obsessing over them
that's because they still oppose
investment into public transit so
instead of electrifying Rail lines or
putting up trolleybus wires they can
just go oh yeah just put some battery
vehicles on the lines there we go
environment saved now we can go back to
not giving a [__] about public transit
for the next 20 years in the end the
Budapest started considering running
autonomous trolley buses in the castle
instead of the accuracy midi buses these
are so called autonomous trolley buses
with small batteries inside that can
move the bus for a few kilometers and
then can be recharged from the regular
contact Network this is a good
compromise between the reliability and
efficiency of trolley buses and the
flexibility of battery buses minus all
the enormous fire risks and road damage
though in the end if trolleybus is in
the castle work out eventually they will
put up proper trollbus wires about rude
solving the castle bus issue once and
for all with a practical economical and
sustainable mode of Transit